I love this headline from TechCrunch  because it's unbelievably true one of  the things I think a lot about is  customer retention of data you already  have we spend so much money on content  and ads to get new customers meanwhile  uh something I call lapse customers  something everyone calls it lapse  customers these are just customers that  are out of rotation they used to buy  from you and now they don't but you're  sitting on the email the phone number  the address I've been doing a ton of  this at winetext.com sign up uh and  Brandon my best friend growing up we did  baseball card shows with me and helped  me build Wine Library has been marveling  at the success over the last three four  five months as we focus on customers who  haven't bought from us in 12 24 36 48  months for so many of you you're  actually sitting with the growth in your  database in your CRM but you're so  focused on new ones you take the rant of  what you've already had rekindle them  now